From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
So Miss Tamer, we were talking about when you were out at Alcorn in the early 1940s.
Can you tell me what it was like?
The campus was the building. We didn't have that many buildings on the campus.
They were far apart. I was out there about two months ago. It looked like a city beside what we had.
Were there most of the main gong? Were there mostly females on the campus?
The world was in hot, really going fast for the black community. There were a few millions on campus.
And you said you went to Alcorn for two years?
Yes, and then I transferred to Tennessee and now.
What made you transfer?
After my brothers had gone to Alcorn, they found out that, well, if we wanted to do graduate work, you would have to do make-up work coming out of Alcorn.
And I found that out when I got to Tennessee because the dean was at Tennessee. He used to work at Alcorn. He threw out all my education.
He kept me there a quarter longer than I would have been there because I was at some school and I would have been out.
I had to go back and pick up that education. He said that education I had at Alcorn was old as he was.
But that wasn't my fault. Alcorn should have all fought better.
Could you tell the difference in the classes?
Oh, yes. Oh, yes.
Sounds like you liked Tennessee.
Well, they were much harder.
Because really, we didn't have the foundation that we should have had.
Even though you actually probably had a better education coming into it than most African-Americans had opportunity for at the time.
I don't know. These children came out to City School with so much violence and we were.
You think that was a difference?
They had his first school, his law school. They were far more advanced than we were.
Do you think that was because they put more resources into it or they had teachers that were more education?
I think they had no money to do something with it. They probably had later books and we never saw a new book.
Never saw a new settle in Cyclopea.
So from what we were talking about earlier, it sounds like that most of the resources for the schools you went to came from the black community and that there wasn't much contribution from the government.
I think they were supposed to have given us, but they took the, always took the best for our children and we got what left over.
What did you do after you left Tennessee? And did you graduate with your...
I graduated in 1947. I got a bachelor degree in home in Kilimanjee.
What did you do? I could find a job in Jasper County and I taught home to get to know me in Jasper County.
I believed it was three years. Then I came to Jones County. If I'm Jones County, I came to Forest County.
I taught home to get to know me several years in Forest County.
What made you move from one school to another?
Battle Sauron. You from then to pay.
What were those schools like that you were teaching in?
There was just a step ahead of the high school I finished with.
We didn't have the resources for the children. But we did the best we could as teachers.
We had a lot of college graduates by the time I was teaching.
They didn't have them when I was going to school.
They might have had more and I can think they were one or two graduate from college.
Most of them were finished at those in normal schools.
I know people could teach with a high school degree in those early years.
If they could pass that test in the superintendent's office, which he couldn't pass.
So that was the white superintendent?
They couldn't help you with anything when you were on that.
I know when I was making my first home and getting out with a reporter, I went on and asked him if he could have the forms.
He said no. Look at what the other teachers used to teach you.
Like that.
Where would your report go to?
It would go to the county.
I think they would send it to the state. I don't know where it would go after then.
But we had to make reports.
Was it related to the county extension?
Yes.
How did you meet Mr. Daymer?
They needed a home economic teacher now here.
When they came up there and I was available, I was available because it paid more money.
So you were available because you wanted to be available?
Well, the money would make you available.
So you came and you were teaching in Hattisburg in Fortes County?
Teaching in Fortes County right out there.
What Dennis went out there for the first time?
So you were right here in Kelly's cell.
Right in Kelly's cell.
Do you remember when you met Mr. Daymer for the first time?
I went to my house here and several more people came up there to be about the job.
And of course I was cooking down there.
And they didn't leave until 8.
They stayed for dinner.
You were going to get them out.
And I don't know if they was even invited for dinner.
But they said we were probably invited.
They probably, but he didn't need to eat.
I know that much.
Was it inevitable after that moment?
No.
It was developed later on.
So did you like teaching here in Kelly's cell?
Yes.
I like teaching here.
I talked to the integrated schools.
And after they integrated the school, they told the principal who they didn't have them
who to have, but they told them who not to have.
And my name was on that list.
So was that in 1970 or 1966?
I know that they integrated at different times.
Now they integrated in?
Was it with freedom of choice or was it after that?
It was with the full freedom of choice.
I think consolidated all the black schools in Forest County into one school.
And they were named at Earl Travegan.
And that's when they didn't rehire you?
That's when they didn't rehire me.
They built a new school around there for all the black students in Forest County.
The white school kept the schools where they were.
The auditorium had to pass by them going to that school.
And that was probably in the late 50s or 60s?
I believe it was in the 50s, I believe it.
And so when they consolidated at Earl Travegan, you stopped teaching?
I stopped teaching in Forest County.
I was the leader, the same year I believe it's consolidated.
I was able to get a job in Paracabra.
Where is Paracabra? How far away is that?
30 miles, Rister.
And were you still teaching home economic?
No. That is how I went up.
By then I had gone to Elmerman.
I had gone to Elmerman before I left Forest County.
I went to the second era first in Elmerman.
Okay. Can you tell me about Mr. Damon?
What was he like?
If I've ever seen a Christian person he was one.
He put Christianity into practice.
He was really concerned about his fellowman.
We had a comfortable living on the farm in the sawmill
and the grocery store on the plane of mail.
At that time we had a very comfortable living.
But he wanted to make things better for other people.
When you married, did he own all this land
or was he working with other family members?
He owned this right here.
Of course he had sisters in brother that own land.
He was working some of that land.
Okay. So he worked his own land and their land?
Uh-huh. And some of that land.
Before you had children who helped him work on the land?
He had hired help. He had hired help.
And of course he had tractors.
I tractors and do farm old living in a horse.
I mean we can't go to plow.
He first started with a one road tractor
and then he moved to a two road tractor
and that was really good to do something.
And then he, as his boy's group,
Dennis was driving a tractor.
Dennis was driving a car and he was 12 years old.
So he's children are in the work early.
Betty was driving a car before she was 10.
That was really good.
All the incident that they burned out half Betty
was just 10 and a half.
And when she was,
I want to ask you about that,
but I thought maybe I should ask you some other things.
When she was driving a car at the age of 10 or that,
around that,
would she do that just here around the place?
Right, around the place.
You know, you didn't know to get out on the road.
Maybe she'd go from the house or maybe up to an aunt's house on the road.
But the traffic was not that like it is now.
It wasn't as dangerous.
They didn't have to have a driver license around here.
Children on the farm learned to drive early.
Because all you need you to do is get off the gas
and let the truck roll.
Then get on the brakes to stop the truck from rolling.
And when they keep on doing that,
somebody just used to go and put it in the airfoam.
But they learned to put it in that one cell.
Early.
Well, they had a lot of responsibility.
Yes. Everybody helped.
So how many children did you all have?
Okay, let me tell you about it.
We had six boys.
Seven.
And as soon as they were old enough,
they would all help on the farm.
Everybody had something to do.
Better to put you in.
She worked all her life.
Even when we were playing cards,
Betty could put the conseys in there.
And they planned on a tractor.
They were liked.
And she would sit on the truck and he'd back up there.
She put the conseys in.
Then this would put the fertilizer in the airfoam.
I was your cooking dinner.
I told you that all the farm you won't dinner right at the time.
If he was coming out and feeling hungry.
So would you cook for everybody working on the farm?
Oh, yes.
Cook for everybody.
That's a big job.
So I know that you mentioned the cotton and the sawmill.
And the corn, peanuts.
And we had sugar cane.
All of that brought in money.
And you also had a store?
Yeah, we had a grocery store.
Did you and the children ever work in the store?
No, he's not running the store.
So she would just take care of it?
The only thing I did, I felt like the report for the sale tax.
But still, I felt like the report for them.
So it's just security for the people who worked at sawmill.
So you would do some of the paperwork.
When did you first try to register to vote?
And that's that.
I don't know what year it was.
Then we all got to meet.
But I was one of the first to try to register to vote.
And he and Hadisburden.
So you just mentioned you were one of the first people in the Hadisburden area
to try to register to vote?
We would go around, feel like, for our application.
Mr. Nene, Nene, never looked at you.
And you would say, I forgot to fill out his hand and turn around.
He gave me a card, a 2 by 5 card with the Constitution on part of...
some of the Constitution on the card.
He told me to read that and tell him what it means.
And of course, I read it and I could very well explain it to him.
He would tell me, oh, you don't know what you're talking about.
You didn't pass.
He never listened.
When you would go down, would you go by yourself?
No, if I don't use you, it would work with me.
So the two of you would go.
He would go there, everybody, because he could go down there.
And of course, they took your tag number.
When you were doing that, is that when they would put your name in the paper for register?
For trying to register?
What they really would do was send it into your employment.
But at that time, we'd already made half a day without...
to organization we gave money to.
And ACP was a no-no, you could not give them any money.
And we had to have that notarized.
So you would have the deposition notarized?
We'd have to have the form that we feel out of the organization that we gave money to.
We would have to have that notarized.
You mean no for the teachers?
For the teachers, yeah.
Yeah, and then that they would fire you if you...
If you gave money to an ACP, we didn't have that nerve to say we gave it to them.
So you wouldn't put that on the form?
No, nobody would put it on the form, but we wouldn't do it.
Were you a member though at that time?
Oh, yes.
Yeah, you remember.
So when you go down to register, was Mr. Damon registered at that time?
No, he never had a chance to register.
He never had a chance to vote.
His card came out to be buried him.
I didn't know that.
No, he never had a chance to vote.
So all of those years are trying?
He never had a chance to vote.
I always go to the...
I never want to vote for absentee.
I never go to the...
I voted once at the court hour when I had a hip replacement.
It was on a walker.
But I always go to the polling place to vote.
I go to the place they wouldn't let me go.
Are any of those same people there?
No.
But they were when you first started.
What was that like?
Well, by then things had changed.
In fact, I worked with someone that was in there.
In his office, I was a election commission and I fought three terms.
Of District 2, I didn't this error.
Did you run for that office?
Yes.
How soon did you run for that office after the vote after Mr. Damon was killed?
These are questions I can not ask.
Were you like the exact dates but was it soon after that?
No.
It was a little while.
Probably some 10 or 15 years after that.
We had a lady.
We had a lady that was running for it.
And I guess I can say this is going to be...
Oh, she had a white opponent.
And she refused to run against them.
Was she afraid?
She said she just didn't like competition.
She was well qualified.
She had a PhD degree.
And she didn't feel comfortable running against the white.
And when they told me we had a...
I think she told the person that was having a...
Who had helped her get in the office.
She must have told her on the third job,
we used to run that she wouldn't go wrong.
And it was one better to run, but better couldn't run because her job.
But then I had retired.
And we got out there.
From Wednesday night, I didn't get enough...
Signature on the farm for a bunch of qualified.
I bet it was...
You had a lot of connections you could draw on for that.
We had a lot of help.
Because we called key people in the community.
And if they were going to sign it, they put their lights on.
We had several people going with farms.
My daughter and I was one of them who was helping me.
She was off from work. I got off from work.
I don't remember how many signatures we had to have,
but we had no other.
We only got to the number they just stopped.
I guess you probably always did more than you needed.
Yeah.
Was it like to be elected election commissioner after being...
...kept out of voting for so long?
It was a wonderful feeling to be able to help with something that they had to die in the arm.
And I made sure that nobody else was denied.
We followed the law.
If it wasn't the law, we didn't do it.
It must have been a nice change to help be able to impact that in such a tangible way.
Yes.
And being able to work.
Now it's only two black ones down.
They were put down on the white, but we got along good.
So the attitude had changed by that time a little bit?
Well, I need to say this, and I've said it.
Browns have been all the black. All white people went there.
There was always some good white people.
But just so many of them were nasty.
That was always some good white people.
Were any of them coming out of their way to talk to you during the early days?
Or let you know that there was some interest?
Or is it just that they didn't go out of their way to call?
Yes, I'm dead, but I'm not going to mention them families.
Because they may have some family friends here still around.
Not only did they white people take culture, do things to them.
They still think what to put them out of it.
Citizens Council go after anybody.
We were talking earlier.
Can you tell me, can you remember when you first found out about the NAACP?
Did your parents belong?
No. I don't think we know about it in Jesper County at that time.
I really find out about it when we came down here that it was active.
Would you have, would you ever go to meetings?
They had the meetings in the house.
In the living room, right here on the same spot.
I sat down on the car, pulled out with the lookout person.
And often the cheaper police came out here one day.
I didn't know who he was, but I was hollering that and telling me,
you need to come to the door.
It's a white man pulled out of the car and when I came out,
I said, chief, what brought you out here?
Chief of police came right out there in Yard.
One on out and made him the people's in the house.
Was this before Curtis and Hollis came out here?
Yes.
This was the early days.
This before they came in there with them.
In Claiborne County, the people that belonged to the NAACP at that time
was about ten people.
They used to burn the cards.
The people that did that around here, they wouldn't want to be caught
with the NAACP card.
I don't remember any of that going on, but it was a very few.
I'm here too, because they could hold a meeting in the living room
and they didn't have some room.
Were there people you knew?
Were there people that went right around here?
Yes.
Were there people who knew and they were right around here?
What kinds of things were you doing with the NAACP?
They were making strategies to British to devote.
They were making strategies to which so much is the only reason
when you're mining with these other county.
Would mega-evils come to those meetings?
No, mega-evils was the state private.
He didn't ever come here to relocate me.
Doory Ladner and Joyce Lachner?
They were young children and they were young.
They said they remember working with the NAACP branch?
Yes, with his sister.
They all was in the same church together.
I wanted to ask, is that Miss Beard?
Yes, they were all in the same church together.
Can you tell me what she was like?
She was very fast-gain.
I came down to hear they were holding this people.
They didn't leave them, could they have?
They just wore it long.
And she worked with the young people on the NAACP?
Did they live close by?
Did they live right out there?
Or did they make an escape?
All of this was in my land.
They all lived right in this area.
So the whole family lived?
The ones that were here, most of the children were no.
They were really living.
Chicago, mostly California.
They were fast-gain.
They just crossed the middle of the summer.
They crossed the middle of the summer.
And they couldn't even come to his funeral.
So they had been going for a while, all day long.
That must have been...
Did you encounter them?
Was he in contact with them?
Yes, the family was in contact with them.
Because when his mother got real sick, one of the brothers came.
I think it would be hard for them to, you know, not be able to come back for something like that.
They couldn't come back for a while.
They had to go for a while.
They could come back to a black man's funeral when they were passing for a while.
When you were having those NAAC meetings at the house and trying to register to vote, were you afraid of her?
Yes.
I answered the door at night, running and asking the door at night.
We were getting threats.
I broke out all the way up here in my neck, all the way down.
Yes, I was afraid.
Nobody wants to die.
How did you cope with that?
Proud.
And me and on him, we were strength to each other.
Did you ever think about giving up the fight?
Well, I knew he wouldn't give it up, but I said it many times.
I was seated.
The last two children get grown.
The rest of them were grown.
There was ten and a half, and then this would have made twelve on the second of February.
This happened on the 10th of January.
I think he should have let them get grown.
But by the time they got grown, I reckon nothing would have been done.
Did you all talk about that at the time?
Well, he kept saying, if we don't do it now, he won't ever get done.
What did you think?
I was afraid.
He was afraid.
We didn't let him go nowhere, and a cop by himself.
Then it's for drive well, even though he didn't have no license.
We told him to get him if something happened to his, if somebody's shooting at car,
and shoot him to get him to the hospital, run the lights if he had to,
and we would deal with that later.
He didn't, he was not only trying to interfere by himself.
Somebody was always with him.
Of course, he always had a gun.
He was one of these people that didn't try to drive when he was going.
He had sea everybody.
But he didn't let a cop ask him.
He would get in the middle of the road for four weeks.
He would let the cop ask him.
He was afraid.
He was shooting.
He didn't know who it was in that cop of hire.
He didn't let him ask him.
We kept the front porch light off because we were afraid.
They were shooting, covered in the dough or something.
I read somewhere, I don't know if it's true,
but that before they attack on the house,
you always just stop keeping watch all night.
We stopped sleeping in shifts.
I was sleeping the first part of night when I got there with someone in the clothes red,
especially during school days for the children,
and they were saying, you're about to school clothes red.
I'd go to bed, and then I'd get up at 12, put on my clothes,
because I thought I could go back to sleep.
Then he would go to sleep, and I stayed awake until today.
Sometimes I would be washing, moving around in the house,
quietly with no lights on in the front.
I had made curtains for the living room in the den.
When we went out there one night,
it could see through the curtain.
You see vehicles through that, so I'd take all of them down and bring in a line of them,
so you couldn't see through them.
It's a blackout curtain, just for the protection of that.
On the outside.
Did people drive by and shoot before the night that they burned down?
Oh, they shot up the mailbox.
They would shoot a woman's out at the stone.
They put up the clans, sign, KK.
They'd nail on my own poles, and he would tear them out.
People's was afraid, and those people who tear you, they went in the parade.
They'd not tear you to the truth.
Did he know any of the people that were doing the harassment?
I don't know if he knew any of my knives.
But they could do on the...
They attacked us and they came out of Jones County.
Did you all ever talk to the sheriff of the police?
Well, true.
What did he do when he was one of them?
If he wasn't one of them, his dad,
it was one of my brothers, one of them, his cousin.
They were all in this together.
When they were used to call the sheriff for these.
Did you ever talk to the Justice Department lawyers
when they had the lawsuit against Theron Land?
Yes.
I was one of the 18 that he had to let register.
That he had to let issued the voter registration card
to we didn't have to go back and register in the mail.
Can you tell me about that?
I want to record in New Orleans.
So did you testify?
No, I didn't testify.
We had very few people testify.
But some of him was the one on the stand most of the time.
But John Doe asked in him, of course.
Were you at the court?
Yes, I was at that.
We were in every day.
What was it like to see him have to answer?
I was glad to see him one time.
He was afraid then.
He was not happy at all.
And so they were able to prove that your applications were qualified
and so they forced him to put you on the road.
What really broke it up on Mars?
Burn on system.
Her name was not beard, her name was not Damon Emotions,
her name was Erlin Beard.
And the neighbor out there on the other side of her,
they were very trash can people.
They went down in the register to the road.
They didn't ask them in the question.
They didn't ask them to read the Constitution.
They asked, oh, he's supposed to work.
What took you so long?
And she told my aunt and my mother and one other thing,
and vote on one of them.
They thought that was so funny.
And she was setting them up there.
They allowed those two people to register.
They didn't ask them if they were black,
they didn't ask them if they were white.
They looked at them and let them register,
because they thought they were white.
So after that, that was the proof that they were black.
That was the proof we needed.
That he was a second gay man against black people.
So were you all the first group that he had to put on the walls?
Yes, the 18th of the kind of camp.
But my mom, 18th of them.
Now, half was one of them.
Burn them was one of them.
I was one of them.
Some old people, 18th of us,
that he had a lot of the reds.
And was that trial?
Was that in Habersburg?
They had the first trial for him.
I believe in Jackson.
I didn't go to that trial.
Because all of the people who would hear that Dakota said
he must have sent us the voter ratio talk.
He did not have to testify against him.
Because you had done the affidavits?
Uh-huh.
But leave them one after.
I wanted to go to court because their turn.
The United States of turnage almost going to be dying.
They were only seeing him.
And they were never taking the pictures, of course.
Does that Bobby Kennedy?
No, no.
I mean John Doors.
John Doors, aren't they?
Okay.
Yeah.
Did you know them?
No, I met them.
Yeah, I met them.
What was it like to meet them?
Wonderful.
They were young, like, young, like, man.
He must have been about 16 and 18.
He had his camera.
He took a picture.
They were going to put him in jail.
He was in the federal court of Austin.
Oh, that man was mean to that young man.
Was that before Judge Cox?
No, that was with the three judges.
Okay, the panel.
Why was un-walfable?
What was the one on the panel?
What I knew all of them when I used to court was the name of them.
I came back in the name of them.
But it was the three court panel.
Uh-huh.
That it was appeal.
Okay.
Um, we talked earlier that, uh, that when SNCC got organized in Kofu, uh,
that Hollis Watkins and Curtis Hayes out of McComb came and stayed.
He went to an HCP meeting and Jackson,
what I knew and they, he was coming back with two young men in this suitcase.
So he went to a meeting by himself and came back and came back with two.
If I didn't have enough to do.
What did he say?
What did you say to him?
Nothing.
He said, they'll be staying with us.
They're going to have with the voter restoration.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
Can you tell me about what Hollis and Curtis were like then?
They were just like our other children.
Here, they had to work like everybody else or whatever was running out.
I don't know how they'd be doing.
They had to do their job.
And then when the work was over with, they'd go out in the community and try to get people to register and vote.
Do you know who they were talking to?
They were talking to people.
They were talking to people from your two people.
And they were hard at times to talk to people around the land.
Yeah.
Do you know how that went?
It went good.
Okay, we're back.
I've been told that he was a very intimidating person, Mr. Laney.
He was his size and his voice.
Yeah.
How would he treat people?
He treated me all right now.
We all were, to all of our people, we were girls and boys.
And what'd you call them?
Well, I call them by their name when I wasn't on their face.
Yeah.
They didn't have anything.
I hated them better than they hated me.
Yeah.
Because of the treatment?
Yes.
Can you tell me what you remember about Freedom Summer?
I did not participate in nothing but cooking.
Getting food out there for them to eat.
And helping with whatever need to be helpful in that regard.
Did people stay at your house?
I don't remember anything I'm saying and keeping them most on live in town
because they could get around better than that.
And they had our children.
They had them trained.
If you didn't have a car, you wouldn't have a wife.
They could walk from house to house like that.
But they did come out here for the picnic.
We cooked food for them.
We was on the fixed food and they had a lady to fry fish for them.
And I was fixing all the potato salad and all the other tree of it for them.
I was doing all that by myself.
Now, did you do, was this picnic for all of the volunteers?
All the volunteers that came nine years of work.
And after stories, it was a wonderful picnic.
It was.
And the young man, I think, had by the end,
had been told they had drafted hell in having a service there.
So he had a young man driving a tractor to go get some melons out of the field.
And still, him coming back the way he told him to come,
he went right through the white community with the likes and white of them at trail.
And that put us scared enough.
Did anything happen?
Nothing happened.
That wasn't the right thing to do.
You know why he didn't go the way he was young and don't do what he wanted to do.
Still coming back across the dam the way he went and come on back up this road and stay in the black community.
He went right out there, but he didn't know how dangerous it was.
Yeah, he knew it was though.
But he probably didn't know how dangerous it was.
That was getting him killed and all the people on that with him killed.
So your son Dennis was telling me that all of your sons,
all your older sons were getting drafted as soon as they turned 18?
Yeah, they made sure they got his workforce around.
Now, I think Vernon Jr. volunteered.
Vernon is volunteered, and Jo is volunteered, but hell and Alvin did not volunteer.
They drafted him.
They drafted Alvin on crutches.
He had heard his foot, but they took him right on in the service.
They didn't care about any kind of injury or...
Well, when I read they knew it had means of tree nails.
So you think that they were doing that deliberately?
Yes, because I misworked for it.
Did they serve in war zones?
I think how was it in Vietnam?
You know, Pindy was in Germany when he died, I believe.
Did you ever go to any of the mass meetings?
No, I stayed at home, kept bedding Dennis.
Were they the only ones in the house during that time?
The only children?
Pound was in here. How did you just come back from the service?
So you had him come back from the service?
He was in the younger children's house at the time.
How did you feel when the voting rights act passed?
Oh, it was wonderful.
That we were able to vote.
And after they passed it, they didn't allow the black people to go up in the courthouse register.
They had a little booth over there where they had sold gas.
That's what they put the registration books out there.
Most of the black people did not register in forest kind of courthouse.
At that time they registered a diamond now.
Because they registered with federal registrars and they rented the space.
Did people start registering really quickly?
Yes, they did.
Was there a strong drive to encourage people?
Yes.
What was going to be the first election?
Was it like a supervisor's election?